really really interests me okay so I
have something to add to the double
standard thing for sure from like a
historical standpoint so originally we
uh were more of like a polyamorous
community and it wasn't until we shifted
into like AG um like an agrarian society
where men were incentivized to have more
children and
um and then women
um were looked at as property because
basically you're like passing down your
seed right and your children are going
to become your landowners so
the men needed to know that the children
were their legitimate children they
weren't illegitimate so if you had
multiple women multiple wives with
multiple children your land could be
spread across and then you'd earned more
money but prior to that it just it was
more like polyamorous
so before that was polyamorous more
polyamorous you know there wasn't the
incentive to
have
your land because we were a nomadic
species but I think that's just gotten
carried over especially with how long
ago would you do you think that was what
are you talking about what part of the
world in the western world mostly in
Europe in the in Europe yeah and you're
saying but when you mean polyamorous you
mean it was like multiple wives and a
small percentage of men because I know
it was yeah 17 men to one or 17 women to
every one man really all right
I think it came from like conquerors
more kind of yeah because they either
going around well you still have that
doing everybody like Saudi Arabia yeah
Yemen maybe all the Arab countries
so everyone's converting I think I think
it was still the same even when when it
was polyamorous where it's a small
percentage yeah absolutely yeah okay
yeah I was thinking the same thing there
weren't really times I don't think we're
one aside from Cleopatra were like there
were 20 men to one woman it was never
really I had multiple husbands how about
husbands but she had a bunch of
concubines she would have I think she
had like thought she was cheating in
herself are you jelly
she had a bunch of like she had a bunch
of these uh like Gladiators right these
muscular Gladiators should call them up
to the Palace I'm pretty sure that was a
thing that's nasty because this is
before
um birth control this is before
stopping STDs you know what I mean yeah
but you can't you catch gonorrhea back
then and you die you did STDs exist back
then of course yeah they did yeah this
isn't a New Concept yeah I don't know
about that
um there's no question that they existed
I don't know all these things discuss
about it so huh I don't know enough to
talk about it I'm glad I'm glad what are
STD's cup s come from well there's a
belief that a lot of the diseases that
we currently have came from you know how
many how much medicine is being pumped
into the market and into people so
things started changing and started
creating you know other things
um I mean
belief of
course I mean you can go across the
board for anything but there's always
been a major shift that as you know one
thing comes about we treat it with the
medicine and then something stronger
comes out
um or hormones being pumped into all the
food that we eat so these are all things
that created something else later on it
was a problem it was a problem that was
solved immediately but just something
else came to be so maybe STDs came about
from something like that I don't know
there's a lot more there's a lot less
disease now than what there ever was in
the history of humanity ever I mean did
you think about the days we had goddamn
leprosy like your arms would just fall
the hell off right we had Polio we you
know we have vaccines for a lot of these
different things now so what I'm saying
is I get it I don't think that what
you're saying is not true but I think
that we live in more of a disease-free
society today than ever before is it
disease-free or I said more of a
disease-free Society well it's not
completely different I mean how many
different medications are there out
there there's a lot how many different
vaccines how many things have we
eradicated out of you know how many
vaccines you're supposed to give your
child when they're born I'm not no it's
crazy you're supposed to give four
vaccines every two months for their
first like six months of life but is it
also correlated that the more vaccines
that we have can it be can it be
correlated the more medicine that we
have the longer that our lives are
because right because leprosy is around
there in a time where there was a 40
year old uh average lifespan right so
we're living longer now than we have
ever lived in the history of ever and
some of that is like knowledge of diet
right like some of those knowledge of
you know how our bodies movement
function but also too it's because of
medication well there was I mean there
was some evidence to show that people in
Roman in the Roman times were they
preached a very healthy Society they
were actually living a lot longer so
what age
they were Beyond 80 years old on average
yeah
so I mean obviously now the average age
in America the average age is actually
not that high
late 70s early 80s probably it's getting
less because the the rate of heart
disease and cancer had gone off
oh that's another great topic that's
like eighty percent that's another great
topic
[__] that British girl is about to come
to the studio
I'm just saying it my manager says I
can't say on my platform gentle belugas
I say beautiful majestic creatures
honestly I should apologize and see for
comparing them oh yeah
I only throw down because
girls came for me
they started it no they did start it so
now I finish it
I was attacked I had hundreds of videos
hundreds of videos on Tick Tock of them
doing pictures of me insinuating I was
ugly okay which is funny coming from a
250 plus to set up a boxing match
well they don't realize that you're as
much as an athlete as what you actually
are I deadlift like 285 very impressive
they squat like 250 like I mean I
haven't maxed out in a while spot 250.
wow solid wow solid numbers I'm strong
I'm glad I still I'm glad I still I'm
glad I still I beat her so I don't feel
bad I'm super competitive like that if I
know a girl can like outlift me at
something I'm like [__] I gotta work on
it I can't be outlifted by a woman yeah
I honestly don't recommend lifting that
much like I
pointless skill that I acquired that's
pretty dope to say you could do it yeah
just take the compliments yeah
so yeah speaking of that man this whole
gaming thing it's like
why in the world are we putting that on
covers in magazines you want you want to
be fat go be fat I'm not going to
congratulate you for it yeah why do I
have to see your blood I feel like being
selfish because everyone's got to look
at you
but isn't it like you know we don't
really preach a healthy Society in
general not at all not at all the money
the money is literally on every corner
you got eight different choices of fast
food and it's all trash I know but it
wouldn't it wouldn't be there if they
couldn't make money doing it because we
choose to eat it yeah but there's again
that I think the biggest problem in this
country is education across the board
yeah so I think most people know the
vegetables fruit you'd be surprised in
lower income communities they don't know
this stuff and they don't have access to
it and they don't have access
how to lose weight
but being able to afford groceries that
are actually healthy as many of you know
I was just banned on Tick Tock and we
are demonetized on a daily basis on this
platform if you want to help please
consider sending a super thanks below
every donation helps and it helps make
what we do possible